we liberal democrats believe in
opportunity for all
in december i'll be in beijing
opening up new pork markets
i can make tough decisions
i am ready to be prime minister from day
one
long-serving cabinet minister youthful
rebel and now preparing to enter downing
street but who is liz truss whose
meteoric ascent has taken many by
surprise she's always been somebody who
has said to herself well why not me why
can't i make it to the very top a
temperament is
one that is suspicious of establishments
um i think she tends to think there's
too much power in the hands of
uh risk-aversed
risk-averse what she would consider to
be defeatists
establishment figures
and that you've got to be bold and
you've got to be brave and you've
sometimes got to take on expert opinion
liz trust was born in oxford and spent
part of her childhood in scotland her
family would eventually settle here in
the affluent round hay area of leeds
this is the street where liz trust grew
up she had left-wing parents and few
conservative role models she was an
outsider but throughout her political
career those who knew her say she was
tough had strong opinions and wasn't
afraid to ruffle a few feathers
as a student she was drawn into politics
but not the conservative sort she became
president of the oxford university
liberal democrats and was seen as a
firebrand
there are two main problems with this
amendment conference
david laws then worked for party leader
paddy ashdown i remember paddy pacing up
and down the press room in brighton and
saying my god if this motion that liz is
moving gets passed that'll be the end of
the liberal democrats and then you met
her again when you were both ministers
in the coalition government i always
found uh liz to be a very engaging
minister somebody it was um pleasant to
work with but she isn't necessarily one
of the world's best listeners that
avoids conflict and blood i remember her
having that meeting with lavrov the
russian foreign minister and he
described it as a dialogue of the death
afterwards
and while i've got no sympathy obviously
with uh with lavrov or the russians i
can imagine
how that must have been for him she sort
of plows on and on and on
her first cabinet post as environment
secretary became known for this awkward
speech
we are growing wheat more competitively
than the canadian prairies
and criticism as justice secretary saw
her demoted by theresa may to the most
junior cabinet post
chief secretary to the treasury
there in charge of government spending
her ambitions took off and so did her
image the treasury was the making of liz
it was where she gained so much
confidence after losing her justice job
she revitalized her image so you saw
kind of a lot of the sort of floral uh
outfits disappear and you saw her wear
power suits and really bold colors which
i think reflect kind of her her newfound
sort of confidence but it's also where
she discovered kind of social media and
she found a space to kind of cultivate
actually who she is you know she's quite
funny she's quite good with puns she's
got quite an eye for making sure a
picture looks good
her colleagues talk of truss's inner
steel her determination to drive things
through
but with a grim outlook ahead she'll
need to build up goodwill with her party
and the public
tomorrow cohen sky news